travis and i want to have a baby
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are ready to expand their family but her
ex scott disick he's not exactly here
for it i mean i think you just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day a source tells
e.t that the push founder and her fiance
want to have a child together the idea
of adding to their bunch is very
important and exciting to them but news
of the couple growing their family
hasn't exactly been a secret travis and
i want to have a baby
put the sample in this cup
we'll take our mics off you know get the
audio that's court and tribe at the
doctor's office a moment that will be
featured on her new hulu series the
kardashians i'm just like living life
and
whatever happens happens
of course court already has three kids
of her own twelve-year-old mason
nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old rayne all of whom she
shares with scott but our source says
the father of three doesn't like the
idea of courtney and travis growing
their family and while scott's against
it the source adds that her family is
very supportive i love it and not only
will fans see court and trav's baby
journey on the new show will also watch
the road to their engagement one of the
biggest things in her life is about to
happen and courtney has no idea
earlier this month a source told et the
two are ready to say i do after getting
engaged last october we're told courtney
and travis are now looking at dates in
the spring and summer for their big day
they want their wedding to speak on
behalf of both their styles with some
sexiness and elegance over the last year
we've seen such transformations from all
of us
this is day one and turns out the pair
is super involved in the planning
process but according to our source the
mom of three is leading the way amazing
as far as scott goes the source also
told et at the time he hasn't entirely
come to terms with court's relationship
with the rocker but he has definitely
warmed up to accepting the fact that
courtney is marrying travis it's a
sentiment we saw in the keeping up with
the kardashians reunion special last
june it seems like you get really upset
when courtney is linked to other guys
me
yeah no oh the last guy let's all be
honest nobody was happy with the last
one so really yeah scott and everyone
else
i was still there to try to help her and
it seems like the couple isn't letting
anyone rain on their parade court shared
these behind-the-scenes picks the fun
they had at the oscars over the weekend
the lovebirds stepped out for
hollywood's biggest night because the
drummer joined reba mcintyre on stage to
perform the nominated track somehow you
do after the show court and tribe hit up
the vanity fair after party where they
looked all loved up on the carpet
and the reality star's close pal addison
ray couldn't help but gush over the
bride and groom to be how amazing did
courtney and travis look on the carpet
they always look amazing how much do we
love their love i love them and they're
amazing people and they look amazing so
[Music]
you